die nächste preisverleihung steht andy
jameson empire awards in diesem jahr und
das ist das was ganz besonderes video
leute aus deutschland haben die
möglichkeit riesen kinofilme in 60
sekunden zusammenzufassen und deshalb
wird es eine ziemlich lustige preis
verleihen ihr könnt dabei sein wenn er
über 18 seid und eine frage beantwortet
nämlich wer hat im letzten jahr gewonnen
wie hieß der spielfilm der im letzten
jahr gewonnen hat vielleicht guckt mal
hier auf die seite vom den jameson
empire awards das könnte helfen ja und
dann schickt er das an klicks
mail.com und wie immer der rechtsweg ist
ausgeschlossen
macht schnell es ist nicht mehr viel
zeit und ich drücke die daumen